une tronche je fais pas peur j'ai pas
trop les yeux gonflés
parce que hier sur la vidéo d'hier j'ai
vu les yeux gonflés
[Musique]
rien de tel qu'un bon thé pour bien
commencer la journée
ça va grenier pas vu savard hier soir on
était fatigués on a fait une grosse fête
ce soir laboureur en votre boîte de nuit
bye bye sapin l'excellente jour
d'aujourd'hui fait super beau il fait
tellement beau que du coup je me mets à
contre-jour vous me voyez pas ce que
vous êtes prêts pour une grande journée
première galette des rois de l'année et
là vous ne voyez pas elle veut pas que
j'affine mais on est en pleine séance
d'épilation
mais il faut tout partager c'est
important de partager ta séance
d'épilation ça c'est sexy c'est ça que
je veux voir c'est très bon ticket ça et
tu sais quoi ça écrire tes jambes
c'est comme les phares d'une voiture
vous avez trop de chance en réalité les
filles que vous étiez comme ça
ça fait mal ça fait mal ça va qu'est ce
qu'elle dit émilie rattaché au ski parce
qu elle fera je te rappelle que les
canes épiler intégral monde
aujourd'hui j'ai une bonne nouvelle
c'est le jour du tirage au sort on va
regarder qui a gagné aujourd'hui pour le
concours val la tondeuse la fameuse
tondeuse regarder mais qui voilà ça
c'est à toi c'est la tondeuse valent en
partenariat avec valve que je vous fait
gagner aujourd'hui donc et le concours
qui est passé il ya quelques jours
maintenant on va regarder qui gagne et
qui est l'heureuse élue qui va repartir
avec sa magnifique tondeuse pour deux à
bardin je précise
après vous pouvez ton tout ce que vous
voulez alors vous avez vu on a une
chance d'être une belle séance
d'épilation ya quelques secondes on peut
l'utiliser pour quasiment tout ce qu'on
veut
qui a gagné alors tak tak concours
concours concours parfum disait
d'ailleurs il ya toujours le concours
diesel en ce moment qui est sur la
chaîne vous pouvez gagner
vela lula il a gagné vous avez je vous
mets un petit lien là en eau directement
ici pour gagner
le parfum diesel bad je le fais gagner
uniquement quand on atteint les 500
abonnés donc vous inquiétez pas ça
prendra probablement un petit peu de
temps mais on va y arriver et vous allez
repartir avec tout de suite c'est le
concours pour gagner la tondeuse lithium
ion de valve merci valent alors on
regardait pour la gagner c'était super
simple il fallait s'abonner à la chaîne
leaké la vidéo commentée pour lire
pourquoi vous devriez la voir et puis
partager avec un maximum de vos amis
donc voyons voir qui a gagné
alors nous avons quelques commentaires
les plus récents d'abord hop là c'est
parti
jade j'ai mis un like et je devrais le
gagner car il faut car il faudrait
couper la barbe de mon beau père bon ok
c'est un très bon commentaire jade
je t'embrasse christelle bonjour waouh
l'année commence fort meilleurs vins
mousseux grue meilleurs voeux christelle
à toi aussi
les mémos d'un terrien bonne année à toi
aussi et je pense que je mérite cette
tondeuse pourquoi pas pourquoi car j'ai
la barbe
tiens donc lâche rien merci
les débuts d'un terrien et merci arnaud
qui est un ami et les knights
bonjour j'ai participé avec plaisir pour
mon chéri vidéo liker et partagez je
croise les doigts
bonne et heureuse bonne et heureuse
nouvelle année que 2010 est soit remplie
de petits bonheurs éternelle si
seulement 2007 peuvent être remplis de
petits bonheurs éternelle je serai le
plus heureux du monde
merci et les dames muriel des mouilles
et de mouiller excuse moi mais rien je
veux pas écorcher tombant salut je tente
ma chance et je participe avec plaisir
meilleurs voeux pour 2010 est meilleure
vue à toi aussi nu
catherine elle bonsoir bonne année et
bonne santé je veux dire cette tondeuse
pour montbard but fils tout simplement
merci et bonne soirée
merci catherine merci la 14 je
t'embrasse aussi très très fort ensuite
nous avons meunier and appriou merci à
caen l'ensemble au bas d'un cadeau
j'aimerais bien ainsi au bas ne regarde
vous pouvez me contacter même si moi je
vais pas les essayer quoique on sait
jamais peut toujours les essayer je les
frais gagner avec plaisir vous inquiétez
pas surtout il ya la saint valentin qui
approche donc ça pourrait faire un
superbe cadeau car les tondeuses ps
belle gosse blond sur le blog du jour
d'hui merci anne et nous avons jimmy
tondeuse val lithium ion cool très bonne
tondeuse je la kiffe je participe merci
greu est une très bonne année 2010 est
et surtout la santé à toi et à ta
famille challes amis et à très bientôt
chao mois jimmy merci jimmy bonne année
à toi aussi
alors voilà pour ce concours
maintenant je vais procéder au tirage au
sort
hop j'ai l'honneur d'annoncer qui est le
gagnant
comment concours pour repartir avec la
tondeuse val c'est elena c'est elena
elena la tondeuse est pour toi donc
maintenant tout est donc juste une chose
tu m'envoies en message frisé soit sur
facebook sur la page monsieur reçoit
directement sur la chaîne
tu m'envoies un petit message privé et
tu m'envoies tes coordonnées pour que je
puisse fast allemand pour l'envoyer par
la poste parce que sinon je peux pas
encore travail par téléportation ce
serait un grand plaisir mais je ne peux
pas en voie moi tes coordonnées et je
t'envoie ça tout de suite et les dames
sinon tu trouveras également l'email
dans la rubrique à propos sur la chaîne
youtube
tu membres un email avec tes coordonnées
et puis je t'envoie ça le plus
rapidement possible merci elle est là
merci à tous alors par contre elena
pense à un truc
hop hop non je veux dire des licornes
petit peu lna par contre elle et la
pensée un truc il ya un truc qui me
ferait hyper plaisir
dès que tu auras suite à ton 2 le seul
truc au chaud demande de faire c'est de
faire une petite vidéo pour smartphones
et de me l'envoyer comme ça ça me
permettra tu me la mets un sur facebook
est ce que tu veux tu tags sur le tu
fais comme tu veux comme ça ça me
permettra de la visionner ça ne fera
hyper plaisir de voir d'ailleurs c'est
pour ton chéri je crois je vérifie ça
permettra de voir ton chéri
comment ils et ça lui plaît tu m'envoies
une petite vidéo je serai le plus
heureux du monde
merci lna et merci à tous les autres
alors sur ce coup si vous n'avez pas
gagné mais rassurez vous il y a encore
le parfum diesel a gagné vous allez sur
la vidéo je vous devais le lien vous
l'avez directement ici vous allez sur la
vidéo vous mettez un petit like vous
partagez vous vous abonner et vous beat
effectivement pourquoi vous devriez
guinée le parfum vous aussi et je
donnerai
le résultat du concours dès que la
chaîne aura pain et 500 abonnés on y
sera très bientôt avec votre aide ça ira
encore plus vite
je suis sûr je vais organiser
régulièrement des concours comme ça
dites moi ce qui vous ferait plaisir ce
que vous feriez gagné quelles sont les
choses qui vous ferait plaisir et les
cadeaux que vous n auriez remporter
parce que autant vous faire gagner des
choses qui vous ferait vraiment plaisir
si ça vous fait plaisir ça fera plaisir
à moi aussi donc vous regardez vous
mettez un petit commentaire en dessous
de la vidéo il me dit voilà voilà
monsieur grue voilà ce que j'aimerais
gagner voilà ce qui me fait plaisir
voilà ce qui fait plaisir à la femme mon
mari ce que vous voulez d'autant plus
que la saint valentin approche donc si
d'ici là je peux vous contentez je le
ferai avec le plus grand des plaisirs
merci en attendant à tous les abonnés de
la chaîne vous êtes de plus en plus
nombreux à venir de plus non plus mob
rue à regarder la vidéo à partager à
laïque et a commenté donc ça me fait
hyper plaisir aux petites et aux fruits
rouges ça ne m'était préférez donc merci
beaucoup de regarder merci beaucoup de
partage et à priori ça vous plaît ça
c'est un très bon point ça fait super
plaisir
merci pour tous vos retours positifs
c'est toujours délicat quand on fait des
vidéos comme ça de les partager sans
avoir de retour est ce que je le fais
bien ce que je fais pas bien ce que ça
va intéresser
est-ce que je suis sur quelque chose qui
qui vous parle en réalité ce que c'est
un truc qui te parle pas ce que font
ceux qui ne parlent pas donc ça c'est
hyper important d'avoir des retours donc
le système de commentaires pour ça c'est
vraiment extraordinaire donc sur toutes
les vidéos c'est quelque chose qui te
plaît qu'il paie pas tu peux le mettre
tu commentes n'hésite pas c'est vraiment
un truc hyper important pour moi d'avoir
des retours
merci d'être de plus en plus nombreux
sur la chaîne continuer comme ça
n'oubliez pas si vous aimez c'est les
poussent vers le haut si vous n'aimez
pas vous pouvez ce sont des pouces vers
le bas
n'oubliez pas vous êtes les meilleurs je
vous kiffe [ __ ]
[Musique]